ja weil wir waren auch in kleine
konfrontation verwickelt kommt auch
nicht dazu weil immer wenn andere leute
aufnehmen können wir nicht von der zeit
her und immer wenn wir aufnehmen kommt
einfach keiner nach es ist ein gruss
spiel das ist so ein gegenseitiges
interesse das sie erzeugt wird irgendwie
herzlich willkommen begrüßt zu fassen
hier wollte ich die letzte folge war
ganz knapp an den 17 minuten die kiste
darauf gestresst kontrakte er kettet
ostzone das ist übrigens mein
chinesischer kanal glaub ich ausräumen
können weil das nicht unsere im netz
sind ja jahres gefallen wollte
das findet wenn ich ganz gut wir nehmen
zu unmenschlichen zeiten gerade eben auf
wir haben weil luca der ganze ein
bisschen etwas was machst du denn gerade
abitur abitur ist es abitur im abitur
ich halte ja deutscher kam abitur ich
hätte nie gedacht dass man für deutsch
soviel gott verdammte scheiße lernen
konnte das ist unglaublich ohne ja du
bist komitee coni war ein bisschen du
für ein verein wie ein verein ist
ebenfalls an weißt du wir haben wir
haben also wir haben es gerade eben
morgen wir haben also morgen für unsere
verhältnisse und das ist echt also das
ist für für wirklich für aufnahme fällt
ist das extrem früh ich kann mich nicht
an das jetzt mal so früh irgendwelche
ich mir gedacht ich nehme es immer nur
abends aufrechter hier fit bin dann erst
mal allgemein 44 also morgens nicht mal
dann irgendwie da arbeitet einer schule
oder
reisen spitzhacke wenn man die ganze
scheiße abbaus diesen weg nach unten ja
ich werde ich werde doch immer schon
beleidigt was du kannst du nicht ehrt
blöcke mit einer spitzhacke abbauen weil
ich auch jedes mal lust habt zu switchen
und mir meine schaufel zu machen leute
was ist denn los mit ich habe einfach so
viele spitzhacken gemacht und haben
soviel alters ist ungleich alle jetzt
muss ich jeden fall bei mir ist es halt
so wie nehmen so früh auf weil häufig
schreibt morgen an alle die was ich
nicht gerade denke dass hier so viele
leute sind die auch morgen deutsch lk im
abitur haben in nrw wohnen und so alt
wie ich aber morgen ist deutsch lk
nrw-weit abitur termin und ich habe
höhle gefunden
in riga dafür jedenfalls habe ich halt
kein pokerspieler so versammelt weil ich
halt mit zwei plus vier bin
das heißt ich darf nur drei plus und
halten nach oben scheißegal wenn man hat
nur drei punkte abweichen darf deswegen
lerne ich wie will damit ich da nicht
irgendwie eine art prüfung muss und dann
noch mal richtig viel lernen muss und
das ist ja irgendwie auch verständlich
und schüler aber ich glaube ich finde
schon wieder diamanten kinos ich wie
wild lernst du so richtig also im
leoparden tanker sitzt der kollision und
lernt sich an oder ich brauch mal oben
wieder zu oft einen landtag ernst ich an
und ich bin mal wieder zuckerrohr an das
kann man erwarte gebrauchen wie ihr seht
wir sind also immer noch das spannendste
team weil wir waren noch in keine
konfrontation verwickelt es kommt auch
nicht dazu weil immer wenn andere leute
aufnehmen
es können wir nicht von der zeit her und
immer wenn wenn wir aufnehmen kommt
einfach keiner nach es ist ein spiel das
ist sondern gegenseitig ist das
interesse das sie erzeugt wird irgendwie
so die die hassen uns irgendwie alle
aber ich könnte mir auch eventuelle
vorstellt ist ein paar leute wirklich
respekt vor uns haben weil wir wirklich
immer sagen ja wir sind stolz so wurden
von ihnen durch die videos zwischen
deshalb die alle zwei minuten sagen das
wäre so cool sind und ich habe keine
ahnung ob das würde zu große
funktioniert egal
bei dir bei dem ich immer das gefühl
könnte es auf dem schulhof stehen und
mein gott ich meine neuen schuhen
ich bin so unglaublich cool ja genau
weil wir auch grundsätzlich immer so
also ich habe das am podest auf dem
schulhof ich dann einfach mal jede maus
lacher denn irgendwann kommen würde dich
hinstellt und dann musst du immer gehen
so ich war zwar mal wieder bücher weil
ich glaube ich habe ein bisschen genug
um was zu machen machen machen machen
nämlich echt das mittlerweile diana
mitspieler sein gewissen respekt vor uns
entwickeln also nicht den respekt
sondern einfach nur so okuma die können
doch was so ist wo ist unser ganzes
leder haben wir kein leder mehr ja ich
habe nie was benutzt dazu kommen der
inventar jubel war habe ich nicht halten
sich raus und kühl scheiße ich habe
keinen erstaunt ich dachte ich bin am
start
diese leder wofür weil ich doch die hält
lehrer umständen übrigens immer greven
mit norwegen flint und pfeile machen
unseren job
doch die hauptstadt ja ich möchte dir
leder die bücher machen dann hätte ich
vielleicht mal gucken können wir das
schwerter verzaubert bekommen aber hier
ist kein leder
ich geh mal ich geh mal kurz raus gucken
ich gehe ein bisschen raus wo polizei
drauf jedes rad passt ihr gesagt haben
immer gremmel ab die das heißt fall dass
das hast du das hast du gesagt ja das
ist richtig
du hast dich gesagt und fertig es ist
echt morgens bin ich mir so unsicher mit
allem beginnen mit jedem satz den hier
raus bin ich so wie bisher
das hatte auch gerade gedacht halte ich
bin einfach so fertig ich muss mich so
konzentriert sich irgendwie was
vernünftiges auf die reihe kriege bei
mir ist ich bin in so einer riesigen
höhle und kommt einfach kein lob
entgegen
das ist unglaublich ich schaue ich
schaue jetzt mal ob ich hier irgendwie
nochmal ein paar kühe sind weil das ist
das leder dann haben wir im garten
glaube ich lese auch immer heftig die
kommentare hier merkt man ja ich bin
happy aktiv jedenfalls da hab ich
übrigens auch den tipp dass wie greven
sollen wegen flint und für franchise und
hühner alle töten sollen wegen federn
und wissenschaft sind und was man auch
gesagt wurde man bekommt äpfel nur wenn
man den strom abstellt und dann die
blätter quasi automatisch die spawnen
das heißt felber ganz viele bäume aber
nur den stammhalter ja ja ja und er
spart ihr anwalt dann ist es dann ist es
sinnvoller mal gleich ich bin hier
draußen kann ich das erledigen das
einbrechen park für den markt so spaß
krasser krasser krasse erfolge zählen
einfach cool shops einfach der berner
krass ich hab das auch nicht so nicht so
nicht so speed mäßig drauf mit dem mit
dem anzünden wie zum beispiel ein steh
die aber dass er schon tot
das war der hund mit diesem speed ganzen
scheiß q1 kreuzstich richtiger richtige
rotzlöffel kuh jetzt noch mal über ein
ich bin jetzt einfach mal aufholjagd und
zwar die ganze wiese land ich hab mir
diesen tollen gremmel fackelträger ich
hab immer zuckerrohr gefunden
ein alter das ist stark das ist ja das
hab ich mir vorbeigelaufen wurden in die
kommentare geschrieben nicht so gut
zurecht was passiert eigentlich wenn
dieses diesen diese bücherregal abbauen
kriegen wir dann bücher oder oder wie
läuft hat
also wir bauen ja gar keine bücherregale
war ja die versorgungstechnik benutzen
die so ein bisschen sinnvoller ist mit
den mit den mit den büchern an sich ja
verschafft ihnen sagen ja das habe ich
auch schon probiert und aber ich hab ich
ja meine stärke zwei mobile bekommen
also wie sanierten strecke zwei bogen
ich habe zwei bogen
meine damen und herren entschuldigt
diese und vernehmlich keiten in unseren
diese diese diese störungen im kommentar
ich glaube gerade hühner weg am
laufenden band das recht gut holt so
viele federn wie nur möglich weil jetzt
will ich glaube ich mega teuer das
werden wir uns nicht so schnell machen
sticks federn
aber ich denke auch allgemein dass jeder
also wir benutzen ja die pfeile dann nur
im pvp kampf also gegenspieler und da
würde ich sagen dass man da höchstens 45
pfeil aufhören spieler schießen kann bis
er dann vor allem an was ihr schwert
benutzt ja würde ich so sollten obwohl
ich ja schon tatsächlich pfeile gegen
diese hexe in der letzten episode
verwendet hat ja eine hengst die war
nämlich ganze bücher und wollte mich in
den boutiquen
also ich weiß nicht wieso kriegt man
auch flint wenn ich das mit dieser
komischen fackel technik mache weil
irgendwie komme ich da gerade kein ich
weiß es nicht ich kenne mich kann ich
mir nichts aus ich lauf gehabt aber die
wassershow hat jeder nie wieder zurück
aber ich glaube einen nach dem anderen
und auch ein paar bäume weil ich habe
hier richtig viel geld also weg damit da
muss ich erst mal wieder eine axt holen
jetzt laufe ich gleich besser zurück
weil gleich macht wird er gar nacht und
ich bin echt ich bin also ich bin mega
weit in der mitte der map grad ich
glaube ich bin wirklich
ihnen gilt jemand johnny haeusler media
in der mitte völlig ausgelaugt haben ja
genau genau genau dann kommt
irgendjemand ich stehe allein da also
allein hast du keine chance das ist das
ist eigentlich ist das doch mal ziehen
sich beide die rüstung aus beim
entspannten weiß oder kann natürlich
auch sein dass mal irgendwie passt das
ja es ist ja wirklich so dass das machen
wir nur weil bisher würde ich nie jemand
uns nach geträumt es wird liegen uns
also ein bisschen vielleicht auch in
fälschlicher sicherheit
das wissen wir noch nicht aber sollte
immer sehr entspannt ab bei uns ist er
so richtig schwimmen wir mal eine runde
und jetzt soll ich mal darüber nicht
hoffe ich finde den weg conny bin ich da
musst du mich reizen
ich kann einfach die koordinaten sagen
ich meine wenn die folge raus kommt
wieder umgezogen
ja aber war ich schaff das nicht schafft
das ich möchte möchte mit meinem eigenen
orientierungs mit meinen eigenen augen
möchte ich es zu ich hab so viel eisen
schon wieder märz bin ich bin schon
träger das war ich glaube hier bei
unsere alte basis und da hinten ist im
moment bei da hinten ist auch licht aber
ich glaube ich glaube ich hab sie ich
glaube ich hab's gelegtes skelett
operativ sind wir gucken muss man gucken
ich glaube hier war die basis paribas
ist mir halloo da drüben okay okay ich
bin alles lockt krise aber nicht
gewöhnen immer so schön sprüche in
letzter zeit ja alles alles alles cool
ich bin back in der holt mal lieber mal
wie schön wäre auch wenn wir einfach
hier wieder lava das mag ich doch das
mag ich doch ein wassereimer nehmen mich
dollar war
kommt einfach mal eben und aber jetzt
jetzt jetzt kündigte zum bloßen es ist
echt schön mit lava du kannst einfach
ein wassereimer nehmen die ganze last
weg das ist spitze
ja das ist wirklich das ist das ist
grandios so ich bin deiner inneren
unseres supertollen baut sich angelangt
jetzt aber kommt man 100 gerade im bett
das hat mich hat mich ein bisschen
irritiert ja dass der gewählt hat kuoni
stopp der stunde hier hat man in echten
leben dinks mein hund im echten leben
habe ich leider kann unter welch ein
bisschen mehr ausgelastet da kannst du
dir aber darauf verlassen wir müssen uns
auch ohne holen und vielleicht sogar
pferde wenn es geht irgendwie die pferde
also es hat ja
modelagent fährt der wagen fährt derart
entfernt
ich weiß nicht mal wie das läuft wie man
sich wiederholt von crafter minecraft im
titel aber keine ahnung aber die
minecraft wächst ja da drauf ist kann
mir erzählen irgendwas was ich weiß auch
wie man sich ein pferd oder man fährt da
musst du das mit mitleid oder mit
yahoo.com grad
bakondi ja ich hab ich hab eine schärfe
ein versorgungsschiff gekommen
hohmeister stark lockt riesig ich bin
ich also ich bin ich bin glücklich wie
ein engel auf eis kann ich damit jetzt
gleich schärfe drei mal gucken
doch da muss ich noch mal dass eine
schärfe 1 verzaubern und dann kann ich
das glaube ich auch dass weltweit 100
börner aller schärfe drei damit damit
wird witzig wäre fast in lava gefallen
weiße auf einmal alt da hatte ich keine
angst ich keine angst ich mein alter ich
war so krank oder lava will die vor oder
sind da die reihe fall wird er wieder
die salinas nochmals aufgefordert kann
sich am liebsten aber die kommt auf
einmal überall weiße stellen fordert
ostendorf blog auf ein meister läufer
darunter so nach dem motto ich weiß
nicht ob es bei dir gott eben kaputt ich
aber es geht mir klicks in offenthal
weiter auf die zeit bis zur 12 minuten
zu bedanken noch ein bisschen bäume
abbauen das ist zwar nacht ja aber ein
großteil der nicht angst vor nacht und
ich muss alles muss 26 level einfach mal
fahren um ein schwerer stufe 3
entscheiden zu können 26 level das ganze
viel macht wirklich die ganze zeit bäume
ab am besten
ja ja mach ich mache ich alles alles gut
aber ich schaff katholische hochzeiten
haye hat ich sehe also wirklich am
morgen aufnehmen bitte bitte und fragt
nach ob du deine abi klausuren nicht
alle in einer woche schreiben kannst du
mit mir ein bisschen youtube-videos ein
bisschen später aufnehmen ja klar ganz
nrw passt sich die an natürlich ja ja
ich finde ich finde das ist auch
gerechtfertigt das hallo ich springe
durch die gegend ich bin auch also in
letzter zeit bin ich fahre hier geboren
ich spring hier nämlich rum und war
daneben einfach mal vier herzen krasses
nacht gerade ja es ist nacht ich bin
draußen und den schlag ich hab gar kein
ich habe nur ein spielzeug wie
verteidigen kann
aber das skelett das gerät hat nämlich
64 krass das alter ich hab das kann man
nicht sagen ich habe immer noch keine
diamanten gefunden hier unten übel ja du
du bist heute wirklich team um produktiv
aber ich habe so viel goldner also wenn
du irgendwie äpfel hast oder so
diamanten immer wenn ich irgendwie die
ansprüche käufer 10 millionen wenn du
mich 123456 66 mit wem mit den diamanten
erstmal die skelette einfach mal mit der
axt fertig weil ich meine ja schwerlich
verbrauchen möchte und mini zombie halo
reach kombi mit dir ich denke also zog
ich habe einmal in ketten helm bekommen
durch das töten eines medizin hieß das
war schön und so diamanten hey das ist
das ist so mega nervig hier ich hätte
ich muss jetzt sechs meter mann er ist
das schön ist kann ich mir sogar meine
meine hose kann mir doch oben sondern
jemanden oder ich weiß nicht da kann
schon mal eine hose machen die dann
verzaubern und dann habe ich komplett
dir da ist gut aber ich habe es doch
doch ich muss ich mich braucht dann auch
weil ich glaub ich nicht wieso ich auch
mal wieder nen bisschen suchen gehabt
dass man mit den bäumen fertig was will
ich was man doch sagen ich war noch
irgendwas erwähnen und war wollte ich
sagen dass ich mit ihren alten schwert
machen muss weil ich gerade sinnlos
meint ihr schwert verbaut das nicht cool
da ist gar nicht cool natürlich lassen
sich auch noch mal sagen wollte ist dass
ich glaube ich oder er nie gleich ein
bisschen du kannst hast du die ganze
hast du schon äpfel oder so ich bin ja
die ganze jahr abbauen wie so ein wie so
ein verrücktes erst jetzt kommt erstmal
mit das wichtigste dass diese leute
machen
ich komme ich höre ich noch keine
eigentlich bin ich hab ich ihm geheim
jetzt kann er auch mal aber dass das das
muss ja erst runter fallen also ich habe
sechs linie ja das ist natürlich auch
schon mal was es ist super mit setzen
können noch so gut vergolden und dann
erst
anders ist das oberhaupt pvp all dem
noch nie mit setzlingen kämpfte ich wird
dann auch sagen dass ich die folge man
langsam beenden
ich hab echt angst dass wir mit
überlänge hier kriegen da habe ich
keinen bock drauf
dann würde ich sagen ich disconnect netz
einfach mal genau ich das connect auch
einfach mal ein bisschen die bude aber
wie immer nicht juni wird ausgeschildert
sein das ist uns einfach immer so am
ende geht es ans netz und damit es euch
gefallen als bewährt und es beim
nächsten mal wieder ganz gut